so we have reached a new low where
donald trump
will praise anyone absolutely anyone
who says anything positive about him
there is this
thing i hate to even call it that
called q anon some people call it canon
some people call it canon some people
call it quanon
anyway q anon q anon is a radical right
conspiracy theory
it involves a deep state plot supposed
against donald trump a group or a person
or an entity named q claims to have
classified information about it has made
all sorts of allegations
it really hasn't been worth our time to
cover but it has slowly
infected trump rallies and it has slowly
infected trumpism
and it has spread through trump
supporters and it got to the point where
yesterday
donald trump was actually asked about
this during his press briefing
and trump seems to like q anon
and almost endorse q anon despite
claiming
that he doesn't actually know anything
about them take a look at this
during the pandemic uh the q anon
movement has been
appears to be gaining a lot of followers
can you talk about what you think about
that and what you have to say
to people who are following this
movement right now well i don't know
much about the movement other than i
understand they like me very much
[Music]
which i appreciate but i don't know much
about the movement
i have heard that it is gaining in
popularity and from what i hear is these
are people
that when they watch the streets of
portland
when they watch what happened in new
york city in just the last six or seven
months but this was starting
even four years ago when i came here
almost four years can you believe it
these are people that don't like seeing
what's going on in places like portland
and places like
chicago and new york and other cities
and states and
i've heard these are people that love
our country and they just don't like
seeing it
so i don't know really anything about it
other than
they do supposedly like me
and they also would like to see
problems in these areas like especially
the areas that we're talking about
go away i've heard these people love our
country this
is really close to an endorsement of q
anon
if you can imagine something so
outrageous
then the reporter smartly follows up and
says well you know
q anon claims that you donald trump
are saving the world from a satanic cult
of pedophilia
and cannibalism is that something that
you're doing
and trump still sort of says hey you
know me as a savior of the world that
that sounds pretty good trump can't get
away from
anybody who says anything positive about
trump no matter how outrageous or laced
with conspiracies take a look theory it
is this belief that
you are secretly saving the world from
this satanic
cult of pedophiles and cannibals does
that sound like
something you are behind
well i haven't i haven't heard that but
uh
is that supposed to be a bad thing or a
good thing i mean you know
if if i can help save the world from
problems
i'm willing to do it i'm willing to put
myself out there
and we are actually we're saving the
world from a
radical left philosophy
that will destroy this country and when
this country
is gone the rest of the world would
follow
the rest of the world would follow the
president is certainly not saying
that's insane and i denounce it okay the
president is certainly not saying
anything
that they say about me is false what
trump is saying is they sound like good
people
they like me they love our country
and they say i'm saving the world from
things while i am saving the world from
things that doesn't sound so bad
i really hope that people understand how
absolutely outrageous this is this is
similar to a president
endorsing pizzagate this is similar to a
president
embracing there is oh
oh trump's oh yikes okay yeah well
birtherism that that too
i read that um jeb bush was horrified
that donald trump seemed to endorse q
this is not jeb bush's republican party
anymore but jeb bush does bear
responsibility
for this being the republican party as
of today and and i think that that's
really
where i want to focus our time this is
why i keep bringing up
that after donald trump is gone whenever
it is whether it's january
or january of 2025 or as trump recently
suggested
getting a third term january of 2029
that's a joke by the way
the republican party is really going to
have to figure out what do we do with
the trumpists
if trump loses in november he will lose
despite 60 million or 62 or 64
or 66 million people voting for him what
does the republican party
do with those 60-plus million people who
want trump
re-elected what does the country do with
the 60 million people is a different
question which i don't have an answer to
but as far as the republican party this
is what happens when you welcome any
lunatic
who is willing to vote against democrats
for decades
the anti-abortionists come on in the
homophobes
come on in the cartoonish libertarians
come on in
the white nationalists the conspiracy
theorists the religious nuts selling
silver solution right
everybody come on in well they're here
now
and they selected trump in the 2016
primary
and they're reaping what they've sown
and oh now jeb bush doesn't like it
colin powell doesn't like it
as far as jeb bush if jeb bush
is concerned about what he's hearing
from donald trump
come out publicly and say we have to
vote for joe biden
where's george w bush we know george w
bush
is not endorsing trump he's not
participating in the presidential
election
and is reportedly disturbed by some of
the things donald trump has done and
said
why doesn't george w bush come out and
say for the sake of our country
we must all vote for joe biden
this time around and then lastly on the
press briefing just as like a cherry on
top
trump still seems to think that stealth
airplanes which of course
they're invisible to radar trump still
seems to think that they're
invisible to the naked eye take a look
at this is it very difficult i was
asking a pilot what do you think is
better this one this one that one
talking about russian planes chinese
planes
they said well the advantage we have is
you can't see it
so when we're fighting they can't see us
i see that sounds like a really
big advantage to me this is where we are
today
this is where we are today and we may
have four more years of this
it's a real possibility it's up to us to
prevent it we're going to have more on
this on the david pakman show
instagram which is davidpakmanshow on
instagram
you can follow me on instagram why would
you follow me
i don't know but you can see pictures
and updates of my urban garden my cukes
and my zooks i've got eight inchers 10
inches foot longs it's
crazy what's going on out there with my
kooks and zooks follow me on instagram
david.pakman if you are anything like me
you probably aren't thrilled with the
idea of going into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there is a
practical and affordable way to take
control of your health and get
personalized care
from the comfort of your home it's a
service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything and
in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or co-pays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care and
it's also so much more affordable go to
steadymd.com
pacman to take the free quiz see which
doctor is right for you i took their
quiz they matched me with a doctor
who specializes in my particular health
needs and situation the doctor they gave
me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started
just click the link right underneath
this video